Це запису відео якраз Олександр Євгенійович до нас приєднався так що є представники усіх, Павло Володимирович.
Дякую. А загалом, Починаємо наше друге, але фактично перше правильне практичне заняття на яку ми з вами сьогодні.
Для обох команд почати спринт Загалом, наш план. Це обрати створити користувацькі історії і створити завдання на двотижневий період і Загалом, відповісти на ваше запитань.
Перша команда склала тих, запитань ми про них пройдемося Але перш ніж я думаю, що було б добре, згадати все ж таки що ми обговорили на новому занятті, а Загалом, оновити трошки ваші знання, тому чи можете ви мені сказати, що ж саме в нашому випадку піджаль.
Або гнучкі методи.
На Сергій Олексійович хоче.
Давайте можливо, скажу. Я у найширшому розумінні гнучкі методи. Це ті методи розробки програмного забезпечення які надають можливість за невикористанням наявних ресурсів обмежень тощо.
Виконати вчасну розробку програмного забезпечення, за що там за декілька етапів кожен з яких завершиться гарним результатом певною частиною продукту, що можна Наприклад, продемонструвати, замовнику.
Де я Помили помиляюсь. Павло Володимирович.
Ні. Все правильно Загалом, ми в більшому сенсі будемо розглядати скрам той же Л це більш загальний сукупність методів які можуть використовуватися але з крарам це вже є більш конкретна його реалізація а загалом.
Ми можемо почати тут більше будуть питання. Як до мене така сигаретичному Сергій олексійович у нас і те, як замовник або Клієнт і Я думаю, що було Б Добре.
Почати Ми можемо почати з першої команди до другої команди Я бачу Олександр Харченко є до вас прохання.
По поки ми будемо працювати з перший квартал розберемося з питань, ви можете також підготувати якщо священно підготували питання то стосовно вашого проєкту, чи якісь заготовки після того, що ми говорили на стандарти.
Так, є але тільки з Кришт бо я зараз.
Мабуть, олександр зайнятий трошки пограємось на вас то літро шпильніше, якщо є А загально тоді можемо почати з я почну демонструвати екран в асані.
Зараз я відкрию браузері щоб можна було збільшити екран, трошки було простіше видно.
Павло Володимирович поки що не бачимо, вашу, демонстрацію. Спробуйте ще.
Так так зараз я намагаюся я відкриваю браузер тому що щоб можна було трошки збільшити екран щоб всім було видно, навіть якщо це на мобільних пристрах от, одну секунду, так.
Ось це мало. Би.
А все ще Ні, 1 момент, Ось це мало, бути. Те, так Скажіть коли буде Ве екран.
Дякую. Бачимо досить таке те собі Міленьке миленьке.
Ось так. Краще.
Якраз на мій зір колеги А вам як нормально Чи ще треба? Збільшити?
Добре. Так Загалом, тоді можемо розібратися з питаннями для першої команди і там загалом була велика кількість питань.
Але перше питання: це яка Основна мета блогу тут питання: до Сергія Олексійовича як замовника, серед цих який би Блог ви хотіли бачити від першої команди?
Тут. Якраз Я спробую продемонструвати найважливішу особливість. Замовника. Замовник не завжди чітко Він може сформулювати відповідні вимоги.
Точніше майже завжди не може сформулювати в нього є певне уявлення, але це уявлення потрібно з замовника спробувати ви добути тому замовнику треба задавати питання ну, ось замовник ну, що там ну, треба блог ну, що ви не знаєте, що таке блог.
ситуація? Будь ласка, спробуйте щось запропонувати Можливо, замовник, має на увазі, щось таке, що про що ви але він не може це сформулювати.
Запрошуємо.
Так наскільки я розумію, я наміщенко назначила вероніку як відповідально за Але загалом перший документ ваші питання до клієнту блогу для того, щоб роз'яснити вимоги.
Ну, Уявіть, що ви говорите з клієнтом. Реальна комунікація.
Так, давайте.
No.
Dr. Sammers, but… Just some of them.
Дякую. Дякую. Звісно. Це має бути корпоративний блок в нас корпорація монстрів.
І вона повинна мати власний корпоративний блок.
Так через те, що ми є корпорацією монстрів яка має відповідно гарну вірусну рекламу, через ту відеопродукцію що була зроблена без нашого відома ми хочемо як то все це спробувати монетизувати тощо.
Ну Звісно, Власне, Наші насамперед прихильники вони різного віку, але це скоріше буде молодь віком десь від 12 років, ну не знаю, до 120, років, ось десь так але не нижче, ніж 12 років, ми ж корпорація монстрів все ж таки не добре, фей й інше.
I keep opening. That's high too.
Так. Значить, перші категорії це має бути Монстрапедія Тобто, про кожного члена корпорації мусів.
Має бути представлена статична інформація Далі, Кожен з монстрів Ну, наприклад, тощо.
Повинен мати можливість ввести як то кажуть, бути окремим користувачем, тобто Основна мета колобка з запалою це розрізати повідомлення інших, тощо.
інше, так що в нас пухнастий монстр Він також хоче щоб його повідомлення були на певному фоні тобто для кожної категорії.
власний аватар зовнішнє представлення а й ось таку тему оформлення не свого повідомлення у блозі.
Mm-hmm. The creative content.
Так це буде текст і зображення, Але через те що ми так зорієнтовані на молодіжну аудиторію то відповідного повідомлення у блоці може бути включатися те відео та відеопродукція, яку ми виробляємо.
Мон немає але Можливо, ви якраз запропонуєте нам прототип а ми спробуємо його від оцінити через пару тижнів, наприклад.
Postiloquinema
No, most. Chia was cheer.
Звісно, є як то кажуть, утіхами з Діснея інша корпорація монстрів вкрали всі наші зображення таке інше.
Thank you.
Давайте вкрадемо це в них.
Paste torture.
зображеннями. Власне, це є профіль монстра який він заповнює А далі.
Mm-hmm.
важлива Це є монстрів. Бельгії відповідні написи типу тегів, які додаються до кожного повідомлення ну Наприклад, там Дісней масдаль перший нас головний варіант до всього світу там єднайтеся тощо.
Офіційне повідомлення корпорації монстрів і таке інше. Тому я гадаю, що користувач має як шукати Так, і спробувати обрати переліку тигів відповідні повідомлення за певним техом Наприклад, повідомлення з офіційних офіційних повідомлення корпорації монстрів.
Саме так філітрація затегами це дуже суттєво.
Щодо підтримки мультимовності наші монстри це Українські монстри Ні. Ми вітаємо острів з усього світу.
Positive chini.
Але вони мають говорити виключно не українською. А щодо другого питання. Будь ласка. Уточніть?
October. Mm-hmm.
Так. Звісно, Звісно, тому, що коли монстрі зайняті. Монстри на роботі. Тощо.
У цей час наші читачі чекають популярних повідомлень наприклад, дам кожного тринадцятого, числа кожного місяця о 13 годині 13 хвилин.
Ми чекаємо на черговий монстро-пост який стосується того, ну що там колобок з бензопилою знову побував на аеродромі енгельса чи щось у цьому сенсі так що планування це важливо ми будемо планувати нашу монстр, роботу.
модерацію тобто лише після того, як не скажімо, так конкретним мостром, вказано що все гаразд, на на будь-якому випадку, у будь-якому випадку, той, хто є відповідним струм повинен мати можливість довільний коментар приховати.
Mm-hmm.
Через те, що в нас багато монстрів і в кожного є власний фірмовий профіль тобто є аватар є тело для його повідомлення шрифт який він там обирає тощо.
Звісно, в нас буде багато користувач система і головний монстр це він буде адміністратор і є звичайні монстр які можете реєструватися і відповідним чином як то кажуть, вносити свій внесок.
Tuition. U.s. South Maurice.
Угу ну щодо цього. Щодо цього. Ми не знаємо Ми такі.
Love it.
Nikki was…
Gest html css javascript
У А навіщо нам про це знати, нам потрібно щоб було працювало. Це ваші справи? Що там технологія.
He was talking about.
Та давайте що там а в нас є гарне число 13 ні. Не дуже гарне 12 давайте через 9 тижнів спробуємо.
A. Yoko Willika.
Корпорація емоцій завжди до ваших послуг.
Так? Тоді дивіться то ви зараз можете спробувати описати те, що ви написали і загалом сортувати це більш-менш якийсь абстрактні задачі, ми поки можемо працювати з другою командою.
І тільки повернемось до вас для створення саме таких користувацьких історій, чи можливо у вас є ще якісь питання досвідки олексійовичу чи до мене стосовно.
No, poking in my eyes.
Добре? Тоді можемо перейти до другої команди, Олександр яка у вас тематика продукту.
Олександрів. Іванович, увімкнув мікрофон Але поки що не Чуємо якісь проблеми.
Так.
Чудовий.
Uh-hu I think when the…
Олександр Іванович ви вказали, що можете показати Відповідну Екрану копію Можливо, це якраз найкращий варіант.
До володимировичу Так, давайте спробуємо перемкнути щоб Значить, Павло Володимир зняв презентацію має бути ласка, ще раз.
Спробуйте показати.
Doc. It's true.
No, sir.
The robot can design.
Dark.
Isama Hare Shalini.
Yeah.
E kataluk.
Jackson.
Let's say. Bezrai.
I see.
Добре? Тоді загалом. Можете спробувати запитати у Сергія Олексійовича що треба щоб він хотів, від сайту додатково невеличку.
Версію і тепер треба все ж таки, визначити щоб 3 місяці, бачити на такому в магазині.
З продажу меблевий товарів.
Дякую. Тут якраз до речі, 1 із можливих варіантів тобто до того як відбувається така первинна комунікація ви знаєте, що Наприклад, ваш замовник і ви одразу можете показати таку нульову ітеграцію, це версія дизайну щодо якої відповідний замовник, вже може стикати пальцем.
Тобто замість того, щоб задавати питання, можна показати декілька варіантів, Отже, Ну давайте як то кажуть, що ми тут власне, хочемо що ми хочемо ось як я замовник через те, що у вас це меблі з дерева.
Меблі, з дерева хотілося мені хотілося щоб принаймні ось та частина яка знаходиться зліва, та права яка не на мобільних пристрах, вона також була заповнена відповідними зразками з каталогу приклад якщо ми це меблі, з дерева щоб там була відповідна текстура тощо.
Um.
Але в жодному випадку там неживі дерева і таке інше, нам не потрібно жодних асоціацій.
Далі відповідно відповідні меблі, які ми добираємо якщо Ось наші покупці, вони власне виділяють категорії для чого ці меблі, тобто це можуть бути меблі.
клієнт може наприклад, обрати Ну, скажімо, приблизно люди так, що?
Story to speed design. Story to suite design.
А власне так через те, що в нас майстерня клієнт може обрати тип матеріалу наприклад, який він власне, можна спостерігати можна зробити з дуба чи з якогось там іншого матеріалу, тобто може обрати деревину може скомпонувати що в нього має бути наприклад, стільки-то стільців, ні.
набір так і має бути конструктор має бути конструктор умовно власного дизайну який ми розглядаємо як-то кажуть, виготовлення.
На замовлення? Ще що має бути Ну, звісно, клієнт може Наприклад, не скажімо, за певну плату?
Викликати представника нашої майстерні для того, щоб виконати, відповідні обміри і поговорити про дизайн безпосередньо тобто, має бути таке звісно, в нас є окремий окремий салон, в якому який ми маємо продемонструвати відповідними, інтер'єрами, тощо.
проводить по відповідному салону, так що ще має бути у будь-якому випадку, має бути зворотний зв'язок ми як активно просуваємо нашу продукцію ми доступні.
У соціальних мережах, усіх тобто у будь-якому варіанті, І, звісно, ми маємо певних задоволених клієнтів, Ну, інколи не дуже задоволені.
Ми маємо книгу відгуків на відповідному нашому сайті Дякую. Що нам потрібно.
Oh. Should the removal
Yeah, just because of the
На поточному варіанті. Він цілком нормальний. Для початку за винятком цієї бічної частини бічна частина має бути не колір дерева.
Та має бути справжнє дерево з гарною текстурою. Ось такий варіант.
Ну, і ви розумієте, що наші користувачі вони ще мають на телефонах. Нормально.
Talk, talk.
Додаткова функціоналість, тобто як це називається найгарніший варіант це приміряти як буде оцей столу у мене у відповідних розмірах.
Я хочу його подивитися не у такий собі доповненій реальності. Приміром. Це важливо.
Mm-hmm.
І це буде вигідно вирізняти наш сайт від усіх інших бо усім іншим потрібно приходити і дивитися або співставити цю картинку, а наші клієнти можуть узяти і розмістити не все у приміщенні й подивитися наскільки гарно ми працюємо.
No problem.
No, much of, sir.
Ну, ви ж, розумієте, що як то кажуть: за грошима, питання: не стане так що ми чекаємо, щоб це було гарно.
Не відбувається.
І що все, було вчасно наш час обмежений 9 тижнів.
Duck.
Так? Загалом, Ви могли бачити гарний приклад того, що як відбувається комунікація з клієнтом.
Завдання.
Так, перша команда як ваші успіх?
No, informaccio. The copay.
Загалом Дивіться, нам не треба створювати все одразу. Ми спробуємо створити декілька користувацьких історій.
І вже на Тому словійте тут були приклади Загалом, я думаю, що приклад з меню можна було б використати чи на вашу думку, з чого варто взагалі почати розробку.
Байф?
Repository.
Так тобто завдання. В нас це загалом, є тут можна описати що Ну, так це в нас вже завдання. Тобто воно під створенням інфраструктури, загалом, тут можна уточнити яку саме інфраструктуру, ми хочемо я як власник продукту хочу щоб.
Процедури 2 підха.
Доброго.
Створений для організації Апостиль над проектом тобто такий дуже невеличкий приклад того, що ти є під створенню інфраструктури домашнє цього загалом користоцької історії процес створення рефлекситорію.
тим, працювати аа добре, тобто в нас є Одне завдання поки що це створення репозиторію, в кітка що ви вважаєте, потрібно далі сталь у нас є розробити меню блогу.
Mm-hmm.
Верхня частинка оця. Верхня частинка. Ось тут бачите тракйка, профіль.
No, everybody…
Show them. Oh, no.
Mm-hmm. Okay.
клієнту як він виглядає Тобто шапку сайту можна далі меню можуть назвати щоб ка блоги, щоб було більш зрозуміліше і тут загалом, тоді ми можемо сохтщити які є які були вимог, клієнта до шапки, було.
Hmm.
Це було зазначено, що Треба виконати.
No, sir.
Так.
Так. Звісно, в такому сенсі ми робимо одну користувацьку історію і кажемо що я Кент хочу мати під сайті шапку блог для скажімо, для навігації, та пошуку посад щось дуже базове просто шапка-бла і на основі цього, ми вже можемо, спробувати сваритися далі.
А тут якраз таке важлива частина тому що частіше за все власники продукту або продуктовані вони не є технічними людьми, тобто я Наприклад, як власник продукту.
Можу розробити вам користувацькі історії, але які технічні завдання, я не знаю вам треба робити Тобто ви маєте вказати яке технічне завдання, вам треба робити я вам допоможу створити Тому яке перше завдання, поєднане до розробки, шапки, сайту.
Корпорація монстля.
Тобто називаємо розробити логотип, ее сайту для.
історія На жаль, єдиний спосіб зробити. Це в Васані але, також буде досить непогано і в нас тут таке створення оркестр добре.
Розробляємо логотип сайту в нас є вже 2 завдання. Які ще завдання, ви вважаєте, що треба.
No.
Угу.
Experimental ate.
Так-так У нас наші корпорації там блакитний колір трохи зелений але більше там ку кольору, морської хвилі.
Okay.
Проте насамперед це різні блакитні кольори, не такий холодний але пошистий. Ну, ось.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, of course, I guess, you know.
Let's take a… freezing steler blockade.
I want to make sure the…
Так. Власне Пропоную вам такий варіант що ми можемо розбити це на 2 завдання.
Mm-hmm.
дизайн, Це Я його розробляю таких-то кольорах Тут будуть кнопки такий загальний дуже простенький.
Дизайн як вам така пропозиція.
I'm only about to be home and paint you.
Так. Розробник також може бути тут все дуже Ми Ми не обмежуємо станції. Але знову ж таки, ви можете сказати: Ні, ми хочемо ось таке завдання.
І Я цілком прислухаюся.
You know, the vital.
The extra tuck to bring this decision.
Так Загалом, дивіться можна розробити початковий дизайн було б використовуючи чотирма тобто розробите дизайн загальний знову ж таки, я зазначив дизайн.
Не обов'язково має бути ідеальним. Ось тут. Так. Сергій Олексійович.
Mm-hmm.
втручання.
це може зробити розробник Але зробити Спершу дизайн, а потім вже розробляти, потому ти знаємо, щоб було зрозуміло, як це має виглядати це все ж таки на сайті.
Latte. To move.
Розробити дизайн-блог Загалом, ми можемо в деталях вказати, що В.
Що в нас має бути обов'язково при виконати, то нам треба розуміти, як зрозумів, що завдання, виконане та які будуть умови, того, що завдання, виконано що ви розробник можете далі.
Рухатись що для вас буде обов'язково мати.
So, yeah, superno
Добре зазначимо зараз загалом що дизайн має кричати, логотип хлопці.
Реєстрації так входу на сайт, мабуть, ага треба зазначити, кольори, все ж таки і який саме кольори.
Mm-hmm. No, siras.
А в нас є кольори загалом Чи потрібно ще щось ще вистачить такого для базового дизайну?
Добре зазнач що дисайн може бути виконаний будь якій доступність правда, як на жаль, добре тобто, у нас є дизайн, і далі.
That's always the designer.
Тоді наступне завдання. Залежно від.
Все ж таки Тоді Розробка шапки. Самі Правильно?
Рим.
Можна так принести дизайну програмну частину себе так космос завдання ось таке кажемо що це бдажте.
Що тут у нас має що ми хочемо бачити, як результат?
No.
Добре тоді має бути перенесений дизайн шапки Хай що тут перенесення дизайну, шапки сайтом.
Just minus.
І.
Якщо можливо, то, розробити то так. Ти О, ви казали: Так. Тобто, можна додати у нас таке простеньке запитання в якому можливо, але важливо.
Mm-hmm.
І не додавати Тобто тут буде побажання користувачів? Розробки добре в нас тоді є 4 завдання тут верпиталь як ви оцінюєте свої екоцінці себе, на те, що чи вчить цього на двох тижневий відрізок розробка Чи все-таки мабуть, треба ще?
With no show
Dati. Nacho muy designo.
З.
Там.
Дивіться тоді можна Загалом, створити також декілька завдань.
Glasabarata.
завдань, яких ми думаємо, що це можливо, але можливо, це буде виглядати по-іншому.
користувацьку історію сторінка.
Блог.
То він конкретного блоку так тобто я можу показати що я.
Mm-hmm.
Клієнт: хочу мати сторінку Г.
Okay.
Для блогу.
Щоб Ее.
Публікувати інформацію щось дуже так сторінка блогу і на основі цього ми вже зможемо спробувати створити конкретні завдання.
Наприклад, перше, ми можемо робити що все ж таки, мабуть, дизайн спробувати зробити Чи ви вважаєте, що можна спробувати лише технічну частину заради.
сайту от у нас є розвиток конкретний блог і на основі цього чи будемо виходити то вважаєте, що потрібно розуміти розробити повстань.
Tacos with China.
Що?
Тобто зробити дизайн стрім під блогом А зараз В.
Це спроба створити дизайн не є фінальним. Але ми спробуємо вкажемо що це завдання і покажемо що це буде поєднано до так що наприклад, і мабуть, тоді все ж таки, інше.
Завдання саме таке розробка сторінки блогу Правильно?
Тоді поєднуємо гостям, розробити порівнюють підлогу, в нас і гові зробленого призайн тобто Тепер у нас є більш завдань.
Знову ж таки, ми можемо ще додавати завдання. Створювати я думаю, що для початку. Це буде цілком адекватна ціль.
В нас є 9 завгодно загалом і 6 в сумі це буде мінус 3 пристосованих історій.
попередньо так Чи вважаєте ви що потрібно ще щось Чи можемо лишити поки що на такому питанні?
Добре тоді загалом у вас є завдання. Ви можете обговорити між собою як команда те, що хоче робити і далі.
Thank you, Shale.
На основі цього виходити вже коли ви берете завдання ви виграємо собі, зазначаєте ви самі ставите себе, і переносити, його що треба зробити, або в процесі розробки так що ви вже взяли і цей процес розраховує переносити його процес і коли воно зроблене ви його притягуєте зроблено.
Але якщо знову ж таки, будуть якісь питання. Ми це можемо завжди розглянути на так.
Mm-hmm.
Так.
No. To put WordPress.
No, it's about. No.
Тут Звісно, питання. Наскільки я знаю що курсом? Передбачено. Все ж таки розробка на реакції, і як пакет можливо, чанку.
А я пішла. Сергійович Так, сказати точніше.
Так.
Tax shop.
Сергій Кіч.
радянські часи інститут автоматики Він був 1 із розробників програмного забезпечення наприклад, для тих самих батискафів, номер 2 які використав камерон при зйомці титаніку і Ось, він розповідав реальну історію що в них.
останньому шляху були поставлене у залежність навіть питання щодо оплати якщо не буде змінена в 5 на ту клавішу яка йому подобається була Команда, розробників витратила купу часу на власне бек-інженерів.
інша мова програмування. Це ячмінь. Тобто ви маєте вкластися в те щоб відповідним чином, її опанувати джанго був обраний виходячи з того, що у вас вже є знання мови пітон і власне кажучи, на ці знання додаються те, що стосується власне Безпосередньо веб-програмування, так що саме
іншої технології іншої мови програмування і витрачаєте час джанго привабливим.
Але вимагає більше частин, які стосуються попереднього такого підготовчої роботи, тобто замість того, щоб узяти готовий, продукт.
Преф Ну, вам не доведеться не створювати програмувати такі речі не все залежить від того, всередині.
Якщо ваша команда має компетенції, пітон реактор, що не має компетенції.
У брати вордпрес це Ризик але взяти інші власне кажучи, як то кажуть, заснований над Жанром наприклад, невідповідний рушій для блогу це може бути цілком доцільною ідея але це потребує вивчення усередині команди тощо.
В будь-якому випадку, оцінюєте ризики ви маєте ліміти і ви хочете що ви хочете спростити на усьому етапі витрати ресурсів це цілком зрозуміло спростили на одному можете видати на іншому.
Подумайте, обговорюють у середині Оцініть ризики і Прийміть рішення.
Doug.
I…
Tomo
I should suppose to block.
Станіслав Андрійович ви чітко вказуєте, що краще? Для блогу узяти дійсно рушій який може бути розширений просто Спробуйте вивчити.
Для себе які інші груші, і для блогів, існують будуть були не такі поширені але ближче до тих технологій, які виводять це буде найкращий варіант не те що найближче є але з можливими проблемами, а скажімо, брати і блогу з тими, технологіями, що не поекспериментуйте обговоріть
Yes, it was a mute. Mm-hmm.
між собою, Можете проголосувати відповідно а Можете щоб все рішення, прийняв технічний лідер.
It's a bit too quick.
Добре, якщо тоді вперше команди більше питань. Немає думаю, можна перейти до другої команди. Я бачу ми вже створили декілька завдань. Добре?
Можемо загалом на основі них створити користувацькі історії пов'язаний тому так само я думаю, зверху.
Спершу замінити фон на текстуру потім у нас розробка вкладки майстерня розробити вкладку огляд товару.
Розробити адаптований дизайн для мобільних пристроїв. Розробити вкладку виклик дизайнера додати меблі з інших матеріалів я думаю, що можна було б почати з саме таким користувацькі історії.
На розробку вкладок, тобто додати, можна погоджуйтесь можна створити користувацьку історію.
Щось на кшталт то давали результати, нові вкладки то продукт.
Добре додати.
Don't wait.
Прити до пані надих ладок Хто проду.
П'яний. Дякую. Кочмати платки.
Огляд майстерня Приклад Огляд товару.
Та і би кут ма дизайда.
Мідь.
Так Проте таку історію. Краще було простопити на де ти для того, щоб писати приклад ми візьмемо Ось цю за основу, і візьмемо лише в ній так додавання.
Пластик майстер до продукту хочу мати кладку майстерня для того, користувачі махли замовляти.
Ага, власний дизайн? Ну, тобто, наприклад, і на основі цього ми можемо загалом, пов'язати його з стаском розробити вкладку, це можна сказати, що це типу завдання.
Треба від.
Так. Тодобання.
Додлайн Кла майстер.
Так. Дивіться, тут Загалом, тоді питання перше можемо першою командою. Перший тут розробка дизайну.
А друге, саме таке його безпосередньо реалізація чи ви вважаєте, що краще буде одним завданням.
Not ideal because of time.
Добре. Тоді ми можемо створити ще одне завдання.
Добре розробити те, знань кладки майстер А добре тоді тут питання що мається на увазі під дизайн майстер-класи Чи ви все ж таки маєте на увазі цілу сторінку.
No, summer… to stream for both.
Ну, так і все ж таки, давайте тоді розробити дизайн сторінки, майстер.
Так.
Ось так і є скажімо, мають бути вимоги до цієї сторінки.
Поруч на тому, що вам, сказав клієнт.
Brilliant.
Designs for
Yeah. The people material.
Тобто опції для розроблених.
Меблів. Так.
Можливо, ще щось тут хлопці, будуть включати в себе матеріали все такого типу.
Що ще?
Lechog or no.
Теплим так Тобто, значення меблі Думаю, це буде цілком доцільно, можливо. Ще щось.
Добре. І тоді якщо ні, то можемо А ти його приїздять сюди і все ж таки розробка сторінки.
Майстерня та до речі, берегти тазуючись на дизайн тобто в нас є така простенька, користувацька, історія можемо спробувати створити ще одну.
У нас були ось такі ось і тепер огляд товару.
Як клієнт ви чумате платку огляд тона?
Принтнують сторінку ольту кажуть, Користувацька Історія і творення сторінки погляд.
Добре, добре, ми тоді можемо його розділити також на 2 базових частини тобто Перша це розробка дизайну.
І Друга це саме таке його безпосередньо реалізація. Розробка зробити дизайн сторінки.
Погляд, удар так, це буде завдання що воно має нас включати?
Це сторінка. Дизайн.
Why am Mr. Through the receipt.
The world.
Добре, я думаю, що Загалом, спершу можна піти з саме таким дизайном. Тому що я думаю, що зробити доповнену.
Реальність. Буде досить складно. З тому можемо звісно окремим завданням. Його зробити щоб було більш простіше це буде трошки забагато тому тут буде наглядний огляд товару, перше завдання.
Розпитує.
Показ.
Меблів або доповнив ні реальність.
Це були також завдання. Ми його поєднаємо з оглядом.
Мару я думаю, що тут можна було б зробити хоча б 1 приклад, метрів 1 2 побажанню чи Як ви вважаєте?
Добре розробити дизайн меблі. Використання Доповнений реальністю є якісь побажання по технології, яку б ви хотіли використовувати для доповнення.
Добре чому це може бути розглянуто в самому завданні то тому що вам буде суть Сергія оцінить.
інтегрується з веб-сайтами. Як то кажуть, тут ви можете це зробити умовно малої кров'ю.
Добре, що такий варіант цілком можна розглянути.
Добре, і тоді нам треба ще одне завдання. Буде це саме таке.
Розробка впини сторінки погляд товар Тобто завдання що мається частина туди включати я думаю, що дизайн що ви ще вважаєте, потрібно бути додати до сторінка огляд товару.
Саме таких програм дій реалізації.
Тобто.
Fuck.
Тоді давайте почнемо з простого це розробити сторінку світ натискань от сказав, ми можна додати Потім нам головне поки що розробити дизайн.
створити.
A problem. Github.
Добре.
Вказують даних.
Дивіться, тут питання. Звісно, можна щоб якщо це локальна розробка також напряму може собі в запускати базу даних.
Dr.
В етапі ви не зможете цього зробити на жаль, або, знову ж таки, можна пошукати альтернативи.
Безкоштовні тобто якісь безкоштовні сервіси, які по типу наприклад, Монте діти, я знаю вони дають дуже простенько мінськоякісно.
Але безкоштовно, бази даних, можна користуватися бо якщо то можна використовувати такий варіант.
Як вам така пропозиція.
Добре! Починати. О!
Для.
І на основі цього створимо одне завдання я бачу ми вже трошки з вами вийшли за час Але Зараз закінчувалися створенням.
Цього завдання. І я думаю, що тоді будемо закінчувати.
Тип завдання? Студана. Тут.
Був Конструктив у команді. Я Думаю, що цілком вас виходить загалом 9. Завдань.
В цьому сприйнятті.
По прикладу того, що я пояснював, і для першої команди тобто можете вказувати, хто буде виконувати завдання, щоб було зрозуміло, щоб 1 людина щоб 2 людини, виконували одне й те ж саме, завдання.
І на основі цього вже розробляти тобто, рухати завдання у випадку, якщо це процес розробки або вже ви просто рухаєте його в секті.
Добре тоді я думаю, що.
Трошки звісно по часу заганяли більше Але я думаю, що ми сьогодні розробили досить Добре, Знову ж таки якщо у вас будуть якісь питання у нас є Щотижневий стандарт посередник, якому ви зможете здавати відповідні питання я думаю, що можна зупиняти запис пре Андрій олексійович.
Дякую. Павло Володимирович. Дякую. Шановні Колеги на цьому Завершуємо.